you haven't seen much of David Hyde
Pierce lately and that's by Design the
frasia star has some surprising reasons
for its decision to stay out of the
Limelight M Frasier was on the air from
1993 to 2004 David Hyde Pierce kept
himself busy between Seasons with
appearances in films like the cult
comedy Wet Hot American Summer and
Oliver Stones Nixon however the actor
also quickly became known for his
voiceover work which began with Pixar's
1998 animated film bugs life what's the
point of going out there they'll only
laugh at me that's because you're a
clown after A Bug's Life ps's Voice work
became more frequent with roles in films
like Osmosis Jones and Treasure Planet
with treasure planets the 2002 Disney
film based on robbert Lewis Stevenson's
book Treasure Island Piers played the
role of anthropomorphic astronomer Dr
Delbert Doppler a role which the actor
claims was written for him however this
early Voice work from Piers would also
showcase a side of the actor that was
unusual ual among burgeoning stars in
Hollywood for G del Toro's 2004 film
Hellboy Piers was hired to provide the
voice for the character Abe Sapien who
was performed in live action by frequent
delaro collaborator Doug Jones in a
surprising move the more widely known
Pierce when uncredited for his work in
the film out of respect for Jones who
later voiced the character in the 2008
sequel Hellboy 2 the Golden Army as well
as two animated films with the success
from Frasier came an interest in David
Hy Pier's personal life which stayed
largely private throughout the run of
the NBC sitcom when questioned on his
dating life during an early interview
with TV Guide Pi's response was evasive
prompting speculation about the actor's
sexuality PS would later come out in
2007 confirming his relationship with
writer producer Brian harrove as Pi
would later explain his sexuality was a
surprise even to him sing People
magazine we did not know at that time
that either one of us was gay and we
just hung out as best friends that went
on for many months eventually we figured
it out pi and harrove W in California in
October 2008 surely before same six
marriage was outlawed in the state in
2009 which the actors subsequently spoke
out against the bound was eventually
rescinded in 2013 despite all the
difficulties that still came with being
an openly gay actor in the early 2000s
Pierce was proud of his decision to
marry harrove and the two remain
together to this day it wasn't long
after Frasier ended that David Hyde Pius
turned his attention from film and
television towards a new Love musical
theater the actor joined the original
cast of Eric Idol spam aot a 2005
musical based on the cult classic 1975
film Monty Python and the Holy Grail P's
fellow cast members included the likes
of Tim Curry Sarah Ramirez and Hank
aeria though ps's role as Sir Robin was
filling the shoes of the musicals
Creator himself in both the original
Chicago production and on Broadway a
year later David Hyde Pier remained on
Broadway to star in the musical curtains
written by Rupert Holmes with music by
John kander in the musical Pier plays a
detective with aspirations to be in
musical theater who is called to
investigate the murder of a star on the
opening night of her play the RO earned
Pi a Tony Award and marked a huge moment
for his career signifying what the next
15 or so years would look like for the
former frasia
star I'm in my dressing room at the
herfeld theater getting ready to do mat
curtains but instead of getting ready
I'm going to sit here and answer your
questions because I love you P's role as
a lead of curtains was singled out by
critics as a standout of the show
reviews also highlighted P's comedic
strengths as well as his chemistry with
his co-stars which included Deborah Monk
and former Fraser actor Edward
hibbit as David Hyde Pier's star began
to rise on the stages of Broadway the
actor became less known for his career
on the big and small screens B's work
was still much more frequent on
television as he contributed voices to
The Simpsons over the years and even
hosted Saturday Night Live In 1995
drawing the prime of Frasier his career
in films however went stagnant for over
a decade Pi's last film performance
before he stepped away from the big
screen was in 2010 starring in the
Thriller the perfect host in the film Pi
plays Warick a man preparing to host a
dinner party when a fugitive played by
CLA Crawford breaks into his house
though it initially seems that P's
character is going to become a hostage
to this dangerous criminal the tables
quickly turn and then even bigger horror
begins to unfold for Crawford's
character sadly this film wasn't beloved
by critics despite praise for ps's
intense and eccentric performance the
New York Times commended ps's
performance but criticized the writing
of his character and the many
nonsensical plot twists that the film
contained
ker one of David Hyde pius's more
memorable film roles was in the 2001
comedy Wet Hot American Summer featuring
an ensemble of comic actors the film
which lampooned sex comedies of the
1980s censers on the last last day of
camp Piers plays a professor living
nearby who agrees to tutor campers in
astrophysics although the film was
reviewed negatively by critics it went
on to become a cult classic though it
was certainly not the successful comedy
blogbuster that Piers had anticipated it
would be he returned for Netflix's
prequel series wet Hot American Summer
first day of camp P's role was much more
minor in the prequel series but he still
delivered a knockout
[Music]
performance
Pi's Ro shrank even more for Netflix's
2017 sequel Series where T American
Summer 10 years later with him making a
cameo appearance over a Skype video call
as director David Wayne described to
vulture Pi couldn't return to the series
due to scheduling conflict so they
decided to make his remotely filmed
appearance as tongue and cheek as
possible hope that was okay let me know
if you want to do it again and good luck
with the rest of the shoot while vision
and film roles became less frequent over
time David Hyde Pier continued pursuing
musical theater success into the 2010s
from 2010 to 2011 Pi stared in A Revival
of Labette in London's West End staying
with the show through its transition to
Broadway soon enough the actor switched
up Ross premiering his theatrical direct
Royal debut in 2011 at New Jersey George
Street Playhouse it should have been you
a musical written by ps's husband Brian
harrove the show which later ran on
Broadway in 2015 tyed daily as a Jewish
mother attending her daughter's wedding
and upon its Premiere in 2011 garnered a
claim from theater critics for its humor
and musical tributes to Broadway
tradition Pi later directed an Off
Broadway production of rip cord for the
Manhattan theater Club in 2015 which
received similar praise for the show's
humor and sitcom
esone after a few years of playing
behind the scenes roles David Hyde Pier
made a return to center stage in a 2017
Revival of the Beloved musical Hello
Dolly bet Midler St in the title role
while PS co-starred as Horus
vandergelder the miserable widower whom
Midler's dolly is determined to woo the
show opened in previews in March 2017
with Piers fulfilling the role until
January 2018 the Revival as a whole was
a Triumph with Midler and Piers
receiving a claim from critics the
Hollywood reporters review stated
there's a genuine spark between Midler
and Pierce and their wonderful scenes
together that helped sell the
inevitability of their Blissful
Union in 2020 the entire world faced the
co 19 pandemic which shut down the
entertainment industry from film sets to
Broadway stages it was a make or break
moment for many in Show Business
including David Hyde Pius who spent
lockdown with his husband Brian although
Pius had suffered through grief before
in his lifetime Co was another sobering
reminder for him as it later tell the
guardian amid colossally awful things
like the pandemic or the war he were
also reminded how desperately we need
the stuff that keeps us going I wasn't
designed to combat a virus read my label
in one sense the pandemic gave PS a
greater appreciation for his life
partner and gave him time to reflect on
the deaths of his own parents this
reflection also LED Pius to embrace his
past reuniting with his former Fraser
kosal remotely to raise money for the
actor's Fund in 2022 David Hy Pier
finally returned to TV to star in Julia
a HBO Max drama series focused on the
life of TV chef Julia Child Pi plays a
role of Po child Julia's husband who is
skeptical of her Ambitions to become a
City Chef the role felt personal for p
who related to Paul's sense of Devotion
to his wife due to P's own
[Music]
relationship to
Julia and her Michelin
chicken however the role wouldn't have
happened had the Stars not aligned
during the pandemic Pierce had
originally intended to do the show
before a Broadway opportunity came up
and Tom Hollander was subsequently cast
in the role but 3 days into shooting
Julia was shut down due to co 19 and
Hollander departed during the Hiatus
with his own Musical on pause Pi joined
the cast as his
replacement over a decade since David Hy
Pier's last appearance on the big screen
he slated to appear in 2023 is the
Georgetown project the film is set to
Star Russell Crow as an actor whose life
begins to unravel while filming a horror
movie and reconnecting with his daughter
played by Ryan Simpkins the film was
entirely shot prior to lockdown rapping
in December 2019 but hasn't been
released yet for unknown reasons it was
most recently slated to premiere on
November 30th 2023 but the lack of even
a trailer means that the movie's arrival
could potentially be delayed like many
other films have been in the wake of the
Stag after a strike hopefully the film
gets released at some point and David
Hyde Pierce can be involved in promoting
it as it would be interesting to hear
from the actor why he decided to return
to film acting after all this time it's
been almost 20 years since Frasier
concluded its 11 season run on NBC
launching David Hy Pi's career Beyond
television to Broadway stardom however
Pier sadly turned down the opportunity
to return to the show that turned him
into a household name the reboot of
Frasier featuring Kelsey Grammar
returning to the title role premiered on
Paramount Plus in October
2023 though Pi is not involved nor does
he have plans to return to the role of
Niles crane anytime soon as grma told
people David basically decided he wasn't
really interested in repeating the
performance of Niles this in part led
the revivals creat to usher in NY C
played by Anders Keith who is
appropriately named David Pi has been
open in the past about his thoughts on
returning to the role of Niles while
never committing to anything perhaps his
perspective will change and the actor
will make a guest appearance in future
seasons of the reboot Fraser I have a
very sore head and a crackerjack lawyer
so don't crowd
me for now the only person keeping David
Hyde Pierce away from more work in
Hollywood is his own ambition to only
take on roles that speak to
him
[Music]